now your Port found that the
Metropolitan Police has not learned from
those failings what led you to that
conclusion well I have done some things
uh and so for example
um back when the port murders happened
they were very restrictive about who
they considered a family so they
wouldn't talk to friends Partners Etc
now they're better than that they've
made some improvement in the way that
that the murder teams talk to local
detectives that's got better right but
still I mean there are about 30 deaths a
day that the police go to in London and
out of that that's 10 000 a year out of
that they'll spot about
150 murders the rest of them they say
are non-suspicious and we don't think
they do thorough enough checks and
they're not well supervised enough when
they're doing them and therefore there's
always this potential that something as
Dreadful as Port could happen again so
what what has led you to think that the
Stephen Port murders could happen again
and what sort of deaths are sort of
being dismissed rather than investigated
properly well the police are called to a
death if it's unexpected so it could be
a suspected suicide it could be some
sort of accident and they're supposed to
do a series of checks and then decide on
the nature of the death and report it to
the coroner and then that's supposed to
be supervised uh and they're supposed to
do background checks on the person that
died and the person that reported it and
take witness statements when appropriate
and they're just not doing any of that
thoroughly enough and they're relying on
luck they tell us they're relying on
luck to see if there was any connections
between two deaths so you know for other
crime types they'll do lots of analysis
of the areas it happens and the type of
uh type of air it might happen in for
unexplained deaths they don't so as I
say reliant on luck to join the dots and
what went fundamentally wrong eight
years ago with those Dreadful four
murders is it they didn't recognize them
as murders in the first place and then
they didn't realize the connections
between them which most people would
have seen as obvious
now the Metropolitan cases issues and
problems and investigating crimes
against women and treatment of women is
is well documented do they also have an
issue in investigating crimes against
gay men I think the families of the
Stephen Port victims would say so we
didn't particularly look at what
happened
um years ago we weren't reinvesting that
case we were looking at whether they are
getting it right now and we didn't see
any evidence of of bad treatment a
different treatment for different groups
now so we didn't see homophobia now
although I don't dispute the family's
view from what happened eight years ago
I think the Met's been in a lot of uh
bad news recently about racism about
homophobia about sexism I think what our
report shows is that the new
Commissioners also got a job on his
hands with some basic issues of
professionalism and expertise now
Stephen ports victims used the grinder
dating app which is how they came into
contact with him and ended up being
killed
do these dating apps make detective work
easier because there is a digital
footprint there's a there's a trail you
can follow well I think in the port case
there was definitely a trail that you
should follow and it's that sort of
thing that we'd be expecting officers
now to do what we're what we were
disappointed by is the what we call the
lack of a intellectual curiosity about a
professional investigative mindset that
on a police officer goes to something
that's happened and has a sort of
suspicious eye and is looking for things
that don't look right what we saw was
just signing off too quickly and coming
to a conclusions too quickly and that
obviously has a degree of risk with it
now the Louise Casey review found that
crimes against women such as domestic
violence and sexual assault were being
dealt with by units that weren't deemed
to be Specialized or senior and they
just didn't have the resources they were
mishandling evidence is that what we're
seeing with these sorts of crimes
against gay men as well I think that's
what what she reported is played out
through what we've found so when the Met
investigate murder its specialist teams
you know relatively well resourced and
quite experienced an expert and they do
a really good job so when a murder is
identified uh the Met get the get the
the perpetrator 90 something percent
very high high success rate and it's
done really well and in fact the port
murder when they realized it was murders
it was a very good investigation the
problem is as you say this difference
between the well-resolved specialist
teams and the the sort of General uh
Frontline cops who are investigating
crimes against women unexpected deaths
and they're not doing it with a level of
professionalism and the level of
supervision they need to be properly
effective